we are going to begin with the
coronavirus and the Global Response
concerning a new variant of that virus
the Omicron strain has been confirmed in
at least 14 countries since it was
announced prompting new fears of yet
another coveted wave now there are new
travel restrictions that have been
announced including right here in the
U.S and we have correspondence covering
every angle of this including the
American response but we're going to
begin with Deborah patta in Durban South
Africa Deborah good morning
good morning this lab here in Durban is
where the country's top scientists are
racing to find out whether existing
vaccines will stop Omicron within 36
hours of discovering the new variant
these researchers alerted the world and
immediately began testing it but instead
of being applauded many believe South
Africa is being punished for its
excellent science
The Masks may be back on but the gloves
are off in the global fight to stop the
new strain in just a matter of days
Omicron has become globally recognized
and is stalking the world
as of today a travel ban will prevent
most travelers from Southern Africa from
entering the United States and
restrictions have been renewed for
travel from Southern Africa to many
European countries Europe was already
the epicenter of an alarming surgeon
covert cases before the arrival of
Omicron Israel has gone one step further
prohibiting All Foreign Travelers with
the variant already confirmed on five
continents South Africa's president Sila
ramaphosa is calling for travel bans to
be reversed saying they have no basis in
science now these restrictions are
completely unjustified
and unfairly discriminate against our
country
but world leaders have committed to
slowing the spread while they wait for
the science because there's a lot we
don't know Omicron is potentially more
contagious than previous strains but its
severity is still unclear it contains
about 30 mutations to the spike protein
prompting concerns from some scientists
it could be vaccine resistant Professor
Anne gottberg of South Africa's
Institute for communicable diseases told
us there will be answers I think there
is good reason to be worried I don't
think that means that we're powerless we
need to collect data we need to
investigate and understand this variant
scientists here won't know the results
for at least 10 days but South African
doctors are seeing an increase in
reinfections in people who've already
had covert while numbers are still low
Omicron accounts for the more than 2 000
new daily cases in South Africa Nate
Deborah patta and Durbin South Africa
thank you